[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
في المانيا بوتين يبحث مسار الحرب وكيف
تعلن حاله التاهب الجوي
الدعم مقابل الاصلاح
الى تحمل مسؤوليات يا تجاه المناخ
والاستثمارات
كويتي اماميه للتصدي للعواصف الترابيه
اكثر من نصف مليار دولار حجم الخسائر
السنويه
في رابع ايضا
رابعه تتجول في عيون محافظه الليث غربيه
السعوديه وجهه علاجيه وسياحيه للمئه
من مهرجان وهي التمر اخلاق تجسيد لاربعين
حرفه يدويه
نبدا من تطورات الحرب الالكترونيه
بما في ذلك المركبات والدبابات مؤكده
استمرار عمليه التزويد كيف بالاسلحه
الجويه ليوكرانيا رئيس الاوكراني قال
بدوره ان الحربه الروسيه غير مبرره مطالبا
بالمزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه
لقد وزير الدفاع الامريكي يوستن بان
باهميه الحفاظ على زخم الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا وذلك خلال اجتماع وزراء دفاعي
دول في قاعده رمشتاين الجويه الامريكيه في
المانيا
ومرحله صعبه من الحرب نحن جميعا ندعم دفاع
اوكرانيا عن اراضيها مهما طال الامر
وسنحافظ على زخم المساعدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيا نعلم ان روسيا مستمر في
اعتداءتها وازادت من كثافتها هجماتها
الصاروخيه التي طالت ارواح الابرياء
الاوكران وشاهدنا وحشيه ذلك قبل ايام في
مدينه نيبرو
متابع معكم هذه الاخبار العاجله حيتاكد
وزير الدفاع المانيا التزام بلاده بارسال
40 دبابه مالدر الى اوكرانيا وزير الدفاع
والمانيا اكد ايضا ان الاولويات الانبياء
ارسال منظومات دفاعا جوي لوكرانيا
في المحلل السياسي ناصر زهير سيد ناصر
مرحبا بك وزير الدفاع الالماني قال ايضا
بان المانيا مستعده لارسال دبابات
اليوبارد الاوكرانيا حال توصل الحلفاء الى
قرار بلديه يمنع الحلفاء اذن من يعني دعم
اوكرانيا باليوبار تحديدا
نعم تحياتي لك ولي المشاهدين يعني في
الاطار الاساسي الخلفاء نحن نتحدث عن اليه
منظومه التي لا يريد الاوروبيين التورط
فيها في ارسال الاسلحه المتطوره الى
اوكرانيا والمانيا بالتحديد تشير هذه
النقطه او تربط ارسالها لدبابات ليبر بي
ارسال الولايات المتحده لدبابات ابرامز
المتطوره ولذلك هي لا تريد ان تكون الخطوه
الاولى في هذا المجال من الاوروبيين ولذلك
هي تحاول منها حتى بولندا من ارسال هذه
الدبابات الالمانيه الى كيه هذا ما تريده
المانيا وفرنسا بالتحديد لانهم في المرحله
الاولى من ارسال الاسلحه وذ ان يقول
الاشهر الماضيه من الحرب وضع الاوروبيين
في الواجهه فيما يتعلق في العقوبات وارسال
الاسلحه وحتى المواجهه العسكريه هم لا
يريدون هذا الامر الذي يمنع الخلفاء
الاوروبيين هو ال- ال- النظره الاوروبيه
التي تختلف عن الولايات المتحده التي تقول
هناك خطوط حمراء يجب ان تبقى موجوده حتى
لا يذهب الامر الى حرب شامله هذه الحرب
الشامله يمكن ان يضطر الناتو الى الدخول
في صدام مباشر مع روسيا وهذا ايضا ما لا
يريده الحلفاء الورقيين بالتحديد المنضمين
الى الناس اغلبيه الحلفاء الان متفقون
تقريبا على مساله همم ارسال ليبارد اثنين
فهل المانيا يمكن ان تتخذ هذا القرار
وتجتاز حاله التردد التي كانت عليه
الى حد هذه اللحظه
الساعات الماضيه كانت هناك مناقشات كبيره
جدا في الحكومه الالمانيه واشار اليها
وزير الدفاع الالماني ولكن لم يتم اتخاذ
قرار بعد اي ان شونس لا زال متمسك في رايي
اذا ارسلت الولايات المتحده دبابات سيتم
ارسال الدبابات الالمانيه الحديثه غير ذلك
الامر مرفوض الى حد هذه اللحظه يمكن ان
يتغير الامر بعد الاجتماع الحالي المنعقد
في المانيا الاساسيه وهما زاد الامر هو
بحزمه المساعدات الامريكيه التي اقرت
بالامس وهي 2.5 مليار ايضا لم يتم ارسال
دبابات متطوره امريكيه ولذلك المانيا لا
زلت في الخط الخلفي يعني يقول او متردده
وهي تقول الثانيه يقول جزء من الاشتراكين
او الحزب اللي اشتركي الالماني يقول
الفكره التاليه اذا ما قامت روسيا بحرب
شامله ووسعت العمليه العسكريه على
اوكرانيا كيف سيكون موقف اذا ما تم ضرب
هذه المدن الاوكرانيه كيف وحتى المدن لا
زالت بعيدا وعن ساحه المعركه كيف سيكون
موقف الناتو الولايات المتحده لم تعطيهم
جواب يعني بمعنى هل سيدخل الناتو في هذه
المواجهه ام سيبقى الامر متصل على التسليح
ولذلك الالمان مترددين في هذه النقطه لكنه
بولندا لها موقف يعني مختلف سيدنا ناصر
قالت بانها ستمد اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات
حتى في ظل رفض المانيا لهذا القرار
بالتالي كيف يمكن النظر الى خطوه كهذه من
قبل بولندا ان تصل الدبابات
الالمانيه عن طريق بولندا
والى اي مدى يمكن للغرب بعد ذلك ان يظل
قادرين على الامساك بزمام الامور يعني
صمود اوكرانيا
والخوف من استفزاز روسي
يعني اذا ما قامت بولندا بهذه الخطوات
اعتقد بانها فقط ورقه تصعيد او تهديد من
قبل هولندا ولكن اذا قامت بهذه الخطوه هي
ستنتهي كليه التعاقد مع المانيا في توليد
هذه الدبابات وهذا سينعكس في مسار تسليح
الندوه الداخلي سيشكل الازمه وايضا سيشكل
ازمه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن تدرك
جيدا انها بولندا بالاضافه الى دول
البلقيه
والدول الاخرى هي تناسق مع الولايات
المتحده اكثر من تنسيقها مع بروكسل ولذلك
اعتقد ان دفع بولندا لهذه الخطوه هو من
الولايات المتحده ولكن اذا ما قامت بولندا
بتسليم هذه الدبابات السؤال هو كم عدد هذه
الدبابات التي ستزود بها كياب وهل ستكون
لها فاعليه وكيف سيعكس الامر على البث
الذي سيتم نشره ايضا في هولندا و ينتظر
موافقه المانيا بشكل او ربما تعيقه
المانيا في مرحله متطوره
حيث اعلنت فرندا
بمعدات الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا باكثر من وعملت
مليون يورو وقالت وزاره الدفاع الفنلنديه
في بيانها ان اجماليه المساعدات الدفاعيه
الفنلنديه لاوكرانيا بلغ 590 مليون يورو
حتى الان المساعدات لا تشمل دبابات
ليوبارد اثنين الثقيله التي قالت انها قد
ترسلها ايضا اذا كان هناك اتفاق مع
الخلفاء
الموقف في موسكو واضح حيث اكد المتحدث
باسم الكريم لنا الدبابات الغربيه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا لن تغير مسار الصرايره مضيفا
بان التزويده اوكرانيا بالدبابات لم يوقف
روسيا عن تحقيق اهدافها بل سيزيد فقط من
مشاكل الشعب الاوكرانيا واستبعد الكلام
للتحسين تحسين العلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده لا في ثاني الى وجود التدخل
المباشر وغير مباشر لدول الناتو في الصراع
وكده المتحدث باسم الكرملين ضروره
الاصغائي لمطالب روسيا لتجنب تصعيد الصراع
وقد بحث وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو خلال
اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره البيلا روسي فيكتور
خزينين بحثاء اجراءات الرد على
الاستراتيجيه واستعدادات ايضا لانشاء
التجمع الاقليمي لقوات البلددين
[موسيقى]
عوده الى جنيه الى ضيف السيد ناصر الزهيري
في ضوء الموقف الروسي وايضا الاتصالات
والتفاهمات مع بيلاروسيا
والموقف كذلك من قبل الغرب وحرف الناتو
سيد ناصر الى اين
تتجه مسارات الحرب اليوم
يعني المسارات الحرب اعتقد انها بالمؤشرات
الحاليه هي تتجه الى التصعيد ولكن التصعيد
المحدود بين قوسين لان الجانبين يحشدون
قوائهم الى مارس القادم بمعنى اذا لم يتم
التوصل الى اي اليه للذهاب الى طاوله
المفاوضات ستندلع حرب شامله من خلال روسيا
على اوكرانيا هذه الحرب الشامله تتطلب
استعداد من قبل الجانبيه او الاستعلام من
قبل اوكرانيا بالتحديد لمقاومه هذه
العمليات العسكريه ولذلك يتم تسجيله
اوكرانيا الان بهذه الاسلحه ولكن هذه
الاسلحه لا يتم استخدامها الان على الاقل
في العمليات المباشره النقطه الاخرى مع
التصعيد العسكري الذي نشره خرجت تصريحات
من الكريم من قبل ايام قالت بان هناك
احتمال لعقد لقاء بين رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الروسي والامريكي بمعنى ان
الحوار الامريكي الروسي المباشر يمكن ان
يؤدي الى خلق ما حول الذهب الى طاوله
المفاوضات بالاضافه ايضا وهذا ما يفسر سبب
تردد الاوروبيين وتصريحات مد بالامس التي
قال فيها بان الدول النوويه لا تهزم
بالمعارك التقليديه او بالحروب التقليديه
يعني بمعنى ان روسيا عادت للاشاره الى
امكانيه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه وهذه ستكون مساله ازمه كبرى في
موقف الناتو المتواجد على حدود اوكرانيا
ولذلك انا اعتقد ان مسارات الحرب الان
ستبقى في هذا الاطار بين الشد والجذب الى
مارس اما نذهب الى التفاوض واما نذهب الى
العمليات العسكريه الموسعه ويبدو وان كان
لا يتم الاشاره الى هذا الامر ولكن في
الكواليس يبدو ان هناك اليه للتحضير الى
التفاوض لان كل الاطراف تريد المفاوضات
نقطه واحده تعيق الامر هو تمسك روسيا بضم
المناطق التي
بسبب العائق لاي تقدم في اي مسائل
المفاوضات سيدنا ناصر وبالتالي
ماذا لو يعني وافقت المانيا على امداد
اوكرانيا باليوبارد اثنين يعني في هذا
التوقيت هل يتم بذلك فعلا تجاوز الخطوط
الحمراء في هذه المعركه اليوم وماذا لو
حققت بالفعل هذه الدبابات يعني انقلابا في
ساحه المعركه امام روسيا ما الذي سيحدث
حتى هذه اللحظه من غير متوقع انها مثل هذا
القرار سينتهي الخطوط الحمراء هو ينتهيك
بشكل محدود يعني اكون روسيا تتخوط او
لديها نقطه تتعلق في الخطوط الحمراء في ما
يتعلق في الصواريخ طويله المدى التي يمكن
تستخدمه اوكرانيا في الهجوم على القواعد
الروسيه والقوات الروسيه اذا ما احدثت هذه
الدبابات فرق في العمليات العسكريه من
المتوقع ان تذهب روسيا الى الاستراتيجيه
اخرى هذه الاستراتيجيه اخرى هي الحرب
الشامله قصب كل المدن الاوكرانيه شانها
جمال جويه باسلحه متطوره والخيار الاخير
وان كان محدود للغايه ومستبعد ولكن مساله
هزيمه روسيا يبدو بانها لن تكون مطروح
استلجا الى استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
يعني يقول بشكل او باخر ولذلك الغرب لا
يريد هزيمه لروسيا هزيمه كامله ولكن هو
يريد ايضا عدم انتصار روسيا في هذه
المعركه وهو يحقق مبدا ان هذه المعارك لن
تندلع لاحقا في جورجيا او مولدافيا اذا ما
قررت
انضمام الى الاتحاد ال- او الانضمام الى
الناته ومثل ايضا حتى انطلب الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي شكرا جزيلا لك من جنيه
في المحلل السياسي ناصر زهير
شكرا
متابع معكم ولان هذه التطورات للبلوش ضد
النظام الايراني في مدينه الزهدان التي
تشهد اجراءات امنيه مشدده منذ اندلاع
التظاهرات بعد مقتل الشاب سامي
الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رابع بعد قليل
مشروع الكويتيه اماميه للتصدي للعواصف
الترابيه اكثر من نصف مليار دولار حجم
الخسائر السنويه
اهلا بكم من جديد
سياسه تقديم المساعدات والمنح دون شروط
اتجاه اخيرا الى انتاج نهج جديد يلزم
الدول باجراء اصلاحات مقابل الحصول على
هذه المساعدات ضمن خطوه تهدف الى اشراك
جميع الاطراف في احداث التغيرات ايجابيه
الاقتصاديه وسياسيه
الاصلاح مقابل الدعم نهج جديد تجاه
المساعدات والمنح التي تقدمها السعوديه
لدول عربيه واسلاميه واقليميه شروط جديده
اعلنتها السعوديه على لسان وزير ماليتها
محمد الجدعان تلزم الدول الراغبه بمساعده
السعوديه بالقيام باصلاحات للحصول عليها
خطوه ستغير الطريقه التي كانت السعوديه
تمنح بها الدعم والمساعدات طوال عقود
الماضيه بهدف دفع الجميع لتحمل مسؤولياتهم
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه فوازير الماليه
السعوديه اكد ان السعوديه لعبت ادواره
هامه في تحفيز الاقتصاد السعودي اولا
والاقتصاد العالمي ايضا لكن على الجميع
القيام بدوره وذلك في كلمه له خلال
مشاركته في منتدى دابوز الاقتصادي العالمي
في سويسرا
ونريده ان يكون مثاليا ونشجع ايضا الدول
المجاوره ان تقوم باعمال الاصلاحيه نحن
الان نغير طريقتنا في تقديم المساعده
وتطويرها وبحسب ما ذكرت منظمه التعاون
والتنميه في مجال الاقتصادي فان السعوديه
تحتلوا المركز الاول في تطوير المساعدات
اعتدنا تقديمه من نحن ومساعدات مباشره دون
شروط ونحن نغير ذلك
الجدعان اشار ايضا الى ان بلاده تفرض
ضرائب على شعبها وهو ما يتوقعه الاخرون
فلا مساعدات دون جهد واصلاح يذكر ان
السعوديه عملت على مدار سنوات على دعم دول
مختلفه سواء عبر تقديم المنح والودائع
والمساعدات دون اشتراطات معينه حيث احتلت
المركز الاول في مجال تطوير المساعدات
وفقا لمنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه
وعلى سبيل الذكر الى الحصر اعلنت السعوديه
عن دراسه بزياده مبلغ الوديعه المقدمه
لصالح البنك المركزي الباكستاني الى خمسه
مليار دولار اما عربيا فقدمت السعوديه
خمسه مليارات دولار كوديعه لدى البنك
المركزي المصري بهدف دعم السيوله
فيديوهاتنا الكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجسر حيا
خلصت الجاسر
اولا لماذا تغير السعوديه مسار تقديمها
للدعم الدول المجاوره صديقه وشقيقه في هذا
التوقيت هل المساله تتعلق
بتصحيح مسار سعودي ام ان حال ربما من
الاحباط لدى السعوديه اليوم بان هذه
الاموال تنفق ربما في اماكن يعني ليست ذات
جدوى او بشكل سلبي ربما كما يرى البحر
منذ الطبقات رؤيه المملكه 2030 قامت
بالعمل على كفاءه الانفاق المالي تحقيق
التوازن الماني ترويح المصادر
تدقيق مختار صفحه الفساد بجهود فخمه جدا
لحمايه وصيانه الاقتصاد السعودي وبالتالي
تنميه وقدرته على النمو هذه المحصلات
تتعرض معها مساله المساعدات لان كانت
تتبادل يعني هذا الجهد المتحقق وهذا
الوفره التي تتحقق تذهب بالتالي لمساعدات
عشوائيه غير مجديه نظافه هذا النمط يتعارض
اصلا مع رؤيه المملكه 20 30 لانه المملكه
تقوم بالتخطيط في كل تفصيل صغير صحيح
وتدرس بدقه وانا سواء حتى في اتفاقات
الدوليه والخارجيه واستثمارات الخارجيه
تقوم على حسابك ثم اساله المساعدات مفتوحه
وممله وغير منطقيه انا اعتقد الخطوه تاخرت
يعني لكن يمكن كان هناك
رهانات على من تتحقق شيء لكن هي كان
المفروض تتزامن هذا الخطا مع بدايه
انطلاق الرؤيه وتقنيها بهذا الشكل اليوم
لما تاتي المملكه هي حصيله لنقل كما ذكرت
جزء من الاحباط لانه كل هذا الضخ وكل هذا
الدعم والمساندات لا يحقق اثر ايجابي في
المكان المستهدف وبالتالي اليوم مثل ما
يفرض البنك الدولي الان لما يقدم قرض
لدوله يضع معايير وشروطه وقولي له اصلاحات
المملكه لا تريد تدخل في شؤون الداخليه
تريد حمايه الطرف الاخير هي خلينا نقول
بشكل هي تفعل هذه المساعدات هي توانس
نهايه تعطيها القيمه الاقتصاديه تعطيها
القيمه التنمويه بدل ما تكون هاجر مالي
فالتاسيس انه نتعاون نحن نوقف المساعدات
لن نغير المساعداتنا لن نتراجع عن دورنا
الريادي لكن سنقرن هذا المساله انتم
بالتالي في الحاجه في الحاله انت محتاج
الى هذه الخطوات لنقل ونتا ان هذا المال
يذهب بشكل صحيح وبالتالي لا نستضغط على
انفسنا في الداخل بينما ننهجر هذا المال
في الخارج بالتالي ما النتائج التي ترجوها
السعوديه في هذه الحاله في السياسه
الجديده من هذه الدول التي تقدم لها
المسمى
الانفاق وقدرته هو تحويله الى اداء فاعله
وكده قيمه للطرف الاخر الامر الاخر
المملكه جزء من سياستها العامه وكما لنا
الامير محمد
تحقيق التنميه والاستقرار في المنطقه
فبالتالي الحاجه ان تكون هذه الدول الاخرى
التي تتقبل المساعدات
تصلها المساعدات السعوديه انت تعمل بمسار
موازي يحقق هذه النتيجه لان هذه التنميه
لا يمكن تتحقق في السياقه القائم الحالي
اذا لم يكن هناك صناعه حقيقيه فبالتالي
هذا تحفيز وحثث يعني الدول ان تقدم
المرئيات ولن يكون المساله اعتباط تكون
على دراسات ماذا سيحدث بالضبط فاذا كان
هناك مبلغ محدد لدوله في حاجه ليست مساله
ونفصل هناك فقط عند جانب الاخر مساعدات
الاغاثيه والانسانيه المسار مختلف لا
علاقه
انسانيه يعني نتحدث عن المساعدات التي
والودائع التي تضخ في بنوك بالتالي
ممدودها الان احنا بنتكلم عن عداء
السعوديه اذا لم تحقق في مصادر ذاهبه
اليها قيمه حقيقيه وتجميد وخساره المال
السعودي خساره لهذا الماء الموجود بدلا
نستثمر في التنميه ويستثمر في المواطن
المقيم ولا يحقق الغايه للدوله المستهدفه
معالجه ومراجعه هذه المساله مهمه وتنعكس
ايجابا عن الدول نفسها قبل ان تلعكس بانه
القنوات بعد ذلك ستتغير يعني لم يكون
الاتجاه بشكل مباشر لهذه الدول ستكون هناك
قنوات بسيطه قبل ذلك يتم التفاهم معها ثم
بعد ذلك همم الى هذه الدول ممكن يعني
مؤسسات ومنظمات
والتقديم والمشاريع المقدمه من الدوله
نفسها فبالتالي ثم العمل على فرزه
وتحليلها واعاده تشكيلها ومدام ملائمه
الالتزام فيها وقد تكون تحدث اخطاء في
المرحله الاولى لكن بالتاكيد في المرحله
الثانيه ونمر اكثر صرافه
الجدعان في همم الوزير وزير الماليه
السعودي محمد الجدعان قال نفرض ضرائب على
شعبنا ونتوقع من الاخرين فعلا الامر نفسه
ان يبدلوا جهدا نريد المساعده لكننا نريد
منكم الاطلاع بدوركم سريع ماذا يعني
بمعنى انه يعني المملكه ليست جمعيه خيريه
المملكه كما ذكرت سابقا قامت باجراءات
كثيره في الداخل ومنها ضرب قيمه الضريبه
المضافه على المواطنين والمقيمين داخل
المملكه لتحسين كفاءه ولمعالجه شكلاته
الاقتصاديه فبالتالي انت احنا متضخه
مساعدات عشوائيه غير مقننه مفتوحه مهمله
ليس لها قيمه رصد فانت تعارض رؤيه الاساس
وانت تتصدم مع نفسك في الدرجه الاولى لا
تحقق الوضوء الان لا انتم بالتالي ليست
فقط المساله الضريبه بشكل تحديد المطلوب
انما ما هي الاجراءات التي تكون فيها
لتحقيق حصانه اقتصاده الداخل المحلي التي
ممكن تكون هذه المساعده قوه دافعه لك وقوه
ضامنه وتساعدك على تجاوز الماسك بشكل
نهائي وليس فقط عمليه التردد هو مؤقته او
يعني معالجه مشكله يعني قلت في بدايه
هديتك انها السعوديه تاخرت في هذه الخطوه
هل يعني ذلك بانه
من الصعب اليوم
الذهاب في خطوه كهذه من قبل الدول تعودت
خلال عقود على ان تاخذ هذه المساعدات هذه
المنح دون اي شروط فبالتالي هل هذه الدول
قادره بالفعل على ان تجاري المملكه في في
هذه المتطلبات اليوم اذا جازا لنا وصفها
بهذا الشكل
السعوديه هذا قرار السعودي بحث نحن سنقدم
المساعدات بهذه الشروط والمساعدات لن تكون
ليست قليله ولم تتراجع اقصد المبالغ
فكره المملكه في دعم تنميه المنطقه سيقوم
على الضخ القوه الحقيقي لما يحقق هذا
السكرار لان المملكه عمليه تبادليه
التنميه تنميه تمتد تنميه اثر فيها هي
ذهاب وليست خط واحد فبالتالي تنمي في بلد
ما هي تنميه العكس على الجميع بما فيها
المملكه هذه التقنيه اذا اذا دوله ثم لا
ترغب او لا تستطيع او لن تتمكن هذه لو
قدمت لها المساعدات المجانيه للمبتغير شيء
لان يتغير نهار هذا هدر وهمان ايضا جزء من
مسؤوليه الحكومه تجاه شعبه وتجاه مواطنيه
واتجاه ادارتها الماليه لموارد الدوله
يعني ذلك ستغض النظر ربما عن غيره المبطنه
من اي الدول يعني
تتحدث عن انزلاق في مسارات فوضى في غيرها
من الامور في توجيه رسائل لدول خليجينا
نتحدث عن دوله بعينه ولكن نتحدث عن بعض
الرسائل التي قد
او التي تشاهدناها في في ايام سابقه في
فترات سابقه وقت من الممكن ان نشاهد مثل
خلافه
انه قد يكون هناك بعض الحالات السدعي
معالجه خاصه رؤيه ستكون حالات محدوده
ونادره وفقا لظروف خارج الاطار وخارج
التحكم والسدعين مثل الحالات الانسانيه
بعض الحالات السياسيه مثل الحالاتفيه
تتطلب عمل خاص ومسار مختلفه لكن في الاطار
العام لا اعتقد هذا التزام من المملكه
بهذا المسار وسيف تم تحديده وتقنينه
الجميع ويتم التعامل على اساسه وفق
المنظمات التي تقرر ماذا قدم ماذا سيقدم
وكيف ستثمر هذه المبالغ وما مردوده
الاقتصادي على البلد وبالتالي تحقيقه
امريكا اشكرك شكرا جزيل الكاتب الصحفي كان
ضيفني فيديوهاتنا شكرا لكم
بعد عوامل تاثرت في الكويت من العواصف
الرمليه والترابيه القادمه من جنوب العراق
بدات الكويت بالتعاون مع برنامج الامم
المتحده للمستوطنات البشريه تفعيله منحه
التمويل مشروع التكيف والصمود للحد من
اثار هذه العواصف يقدمها الصندوق الكويتي
للتنميه الاقتصاديه بقيمه اربعه ملايين
دينار وتمت الدوله
باكثر من 620 مليون دولار وفقا لمعهد
الكويت للابحاث العلميه وستهدف او يستهدف
المشروع مناطق محدده تقع على بعد 200 250
كلم شمال الحدود الكويتيه تعددوا
المسؤوليه بشكل مباشر عن 40% من اجمالي
الغبار الذي تتعرض له الكويت وسيتم العمل
فيها على تصميم بنيه تحتيه لاعاده تاهيل
المناطق المتضرره من خلال اليات منها وضع
طبقه طينيه ثقيله تساهم في نمو النباتات
فضلا عن زراعتها اشجار فطريه مقاومه من
الجفاف وستعمل كما صدات للرياح تساهم في
تثبيت التربه وزياده كثافه النباتيه
من الكويت ينضم الينا مدير معهد الكويت
للابحاث العلميه الدكتور مانع السديراوي
الدكتور مانع مرحبا بك معنا يعني الكويت
الى اي مدى الان هي تعرف كل الاسباب التي
تؤدي الى هذه العواصف في الترابيه والغبار
الذي زادت وتيته يمكن خلال سنوات ماضيه
قريبا بشكل كبير جدا واثره ايضا همم
اقتصاديا واجتماعيا وعلى كل المستويات
لا تحياتي لك اخوي والاخوه المشاهدين طبعا
معهد الكويت لابحاث العلمي ما حد لابحاث
يقوم بدراسات
بخصوص ظاهره الغبار في دوله الكويت منذ
اكثر من 30 سنه
ويدرس اسبابها هذه الظاهره
اسباب ازديادها في الفتره الاخيره
وعلاقتها بظروف المناخيه المختلفه
وتحديد مصادر الغبار التي تاتي الى دوله
الكويت همم من الخبره المتراكمه لدي
المعهد تم تحديد بعض المناطق في شمال دوله
الكويت همم في جمهوريه العراق همم 250
كيلو على الحدود الكويتيه هي كانت مصدر
كبير
للغبار التي التي ياتي الى الكويت وينتقل
الى باقي دول همم الخليج همم
فطبع ان هذا المشروع اللي وقعنا امس همم
يهدف الى معالجه هذه المنطقه كيف ستتم
المعالجه في حده الغبار التي سياتي الكويت
طبعا احنا وقعنا المشروع العلمي البحثي مع
برنامج المتحده المستوطنات البشريه امس
وان شاء الله في القريب العاجل خلال همم
اسابيع او همم اشهر ان شاء الله راح نبدا
وبالحقيقه هم بداوا الاخوان حاليا
ببعض الاجراءات
بحث التعاون مع انه الاسباب كما تقول يمكن
انه الكويت تعرفها لانه سنين والامر يتكرر
نعم احنا نعرف الاسباب بس المصدر هو
الغبار يحتاج الى مصدر للغبار ويحتاج ظروف
مناخيه معينه
طبعا لاثاره الغبار فهذه الامور العلميه
احنا دارسينها وعارفينها همم
وحددنا المناطق عن طريق الدراسات والصور
الجويه المتوفره لدينا مناطق هبوب مصادر
الغبار طبعا مثل ما يمكن الثمانين بالماء
من الرياح عند الرياح السائده هي من
الشمال والشمال الغربي همم وطبعا هذه
المنطقه تقع شمال دوله الكويت والصور
الجويه بينك لنا همم هي مصدر رئيسي و40%
من همم
الغبار لياتي الى الكويت والعواصف
الترابيه من هذه المنطقه فانتقد
النبي معالجه هذه المنطقه ممكن تخفيف حده
الغبار
يعني فردي من الكويت ام انها تحتاج الى
عمل اقليمي لان المسببات هنا قد تختلف
مثلا ايران تقول بان تركيا الاسباب تقول
ان تركيا تبني سدود وتخلف هذه السدود ندره
في المياه وبالتالي ندره المياه هي ما
يؤدي الى تفاقم العواصم الترابيه العراق
قد يكون لها وجهه نظر اخرى الكويت قد يكون
لها وجهه نظر كذلك في هذا الموضوع
فبالتالي ما بعد هذه الخطوه الى اي ماده
هناك حاجه الى توافق وعمل اقليمي موحد
المواجهات همم هذه العواصف
نعم طبعا الاخبار هو ظاهره عابره الحدود
ولابد من التعاون الاقليمي بين الدول اللي
مكافحه هذه الظاهره واحنا على اتفاق مع
جمهوريه العراق بالنسبه حق هذا الموضوع
واحنا راح طبعا ما راح نقوم بالعمل
منفردين راح طبعا الاجراءات الحفر
والزراعه والري
ورحتم حفر قنوات
لراي هذه المناطق واعاده تحضرها همم احنا
ننظر الى الجانب العلمي نوعيه النباتات
التي سوف تستخدم المناطق همم
الرئيسيه التي يتم معالجتها طرق المعالجه
العلميه المعهد يقدمها انما الامل الفعلي
في الحقول طبعا رح يتم همم وهو مشروع
مشترك بانه بين جمهوريه العراق يعني
الميزانيه المرصوده هي فقط لدراسه الاسباب
ولا تشمل التنفيذ او العمل بعد ذلك
لا لا هي هي جزء منها راح يروح لمحد
الكويت لابحاث العلميه لتقديم الاستشارات
العلميه والجزء الاخر منها راح يروح
الجمهوريه العراق
للقيام بالاجراءات المطلوبه وحفر القنوات
والزراعه
ووضع المصادات لان طبعا الغبار هذا مو ما
ياثر بس على دوله الكويت ياثر على مناطق
في جنوب العراق كذلك ويمتد الى دول الخليج
الاخرى
بالتالي متى يمكن ان نرى اثرا ايجابيا
لهكذا دراسه
طبعا هذا من نوع من الدراسات ياخذ وقت
طويل المنطقه اللي احنا بصددها تقريبا
مساحتها 8000 كيلومتر مربع طبعا مو كل
المنطقه اللي راح نعالجها بس في مناطق
تنتهي تحديدها اللي هي المصدر الرئيسي
للغبار همم المشروح هذا مدتها اربع سنوات
حاليا كمرحله اولى وان شاء الله راح يستمر
وفي دول خليجيه اخرى همم ابدات استعداد هل
التعاون معانا في الاستمرار المعالجه لها
كذلك هي متضرره من ظاهره الغبار
فالمشروع مستمر لفتره طويله بس هذه
المرحله ان شاء الله راح تستمر لمده اربع
سنوات اربع سنوات يعني اربع سنوات ستستمر
كما يقول برنامج الامم المتحده بين ما
يحدث على الارض بينما مطلوب من دول الخليج
دكتور معنا
نعم طبعا الدراسات العلميه تاخذ وقت احنا
عايشين هذا الغبار مئات السنين منذ انشاء
دوله الكويت ودول الخليج ايييه فالاربع
سنين بالنسبه
للدراسات العلميه ليست في الكثير وان شاء
الله بعد الاربعه الاجيال القادمه واحنا
في المستقبل ان شاء الله
راح
تخف مشكله ظاهره الغبار بالنسبه لنا
وبالنسبه حق همم ابناءنا في المستقبل هذا
تخطيط مستقبلي ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك
من الكويت مدير معهد او مدير الابحاث
العلميه الدكتور
في الرابعه ايضا بعد قليل
على خط غرينتش مايكروسوفت التي صرحت عشره
الاف جوجل تسريحه 12201
الدعم مقابل الاصلاح السعوديه تدعو الدول
الى تحمل مسؤولياتها تجاه المنح والارات
مشروع كويتي امام العواصف الترابيه اكثر
من نصف مليار دولار حجم الخسائر السنويه
الرابعه تتجول في عيون محافظه الليث
الغربيه السعوديه وجهتنا علاجيه وسياحيه
للمئات
والاحساء تحتضن النسخه الثامنه من مهرجان
اهلا بكم ويتمر احلام مهرجان ثانويه
تستضيفه الاحساء شرق السعوديه للمره
الثامنه
المهرجان شهد اقبل كبيرا في ايامه الاولى
يضم عده فعاليات متعدده تحاكي الاهتمام
بالنخله والتمور ويجسد المهرجان اربعين
حرفه يدويه تعرف بها الاحساء فضلا عن دعم
الجانب التسويقي لتمور الاحسن
لحسين ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد الرحمن ما
الجديد كيف يختلف المهرجان هذه السنه
نعم خالد كبير جدا ربما اليوم ويوم الجمعه
فيعتبر يعني اجازه نهايه الاسبوع في
الاقبال الكبير جدا منذ ساعات العصر
الاولى بعد صلاه العصر مباشره طبعا هذا
المهرجان ياتي بنسخته الثامنه ويحقق
نجاحات متتاليه
واعداد كبيره من الزوار الحديث اكثر عن
هذا المهرجان ينضم اليه الاستاذ خالد بوشل
المتحدث الرسمي امانه الاحساء خالد اولا
خلينا نتكلم عن مصطلح التمور المصنعه ماذا
نعني بالتمر المصنعه تمور المصنعه في
طبيعه تمور الاحساء تكون تدخل دائره ايش
يعني التصنيع يعني تكون مكنسه تكون محوله
الى صناعات اخرى كالمعامير عادت تمور
الحساوي ما تؤكل نثرا بل تدخل في مراحل
تصنيعيه فلذلك في شهر تسعه يتم التمور في
هذا في شاب بدايه السنه يتم عمل هذا
المهرجان الكبير
للمنت التمريه الحساويه ماذا يحمل هذا
المراجل مستطيل الثامنه همم شيء مختلف عن
النسخ الماضيه اخوي عبد الرحمن احنا بدانا
يعني مهرجان التمور في
2014 بدينا في 20 ركن الان لما نتكلم عن
60 ركن مشارك فاحنا وضعنا هدف وهو هدف
التصاعديه في عمليه الانتاج تحويل منتج
التمور الشعبي البسيط الى منتج اقتصادي
عالمي وهذا ما حققناه على مدار ثمان سنوات
لكن متراقبين هذا العام ان يحقق المهرجان
قفزات اقتصاديه همم نظير
التنافسيه الموجوده ما بين التجار في
عمليه تقديم قوالب جديده دخول التمر في
يعني في صناعات تحويديه همم يعني ابتكاريه
جديده
اقبال كبير من التجار ومن اصحاب المزارع
مهرجان العام الماضي السنه هذه ايضا العدد
كبير كما كان العمل الماضي
يحققنا بكل جداره ولاول مره حققنا 700,000
زائر لكن هذا العام توسعنا في عمليه
الاركان توسعنا في عمليه المكان لان
متوقعين همم زياده عدد الزوار ومتكما
تشاهدون اليوم احنا اليوم تونا في البدايه
في ثاني يوم والاقبال متزايد وهناك حضور
حتى من دول الخليج هيستمر الى متى هذا
المهرجان ان شاء الله باذن الله 36 يوم
يعني راح نتواصل حتى ما بعد يوم التاسيس
باذن الله تعالى جميل همم السنه هذه ايضا
في جهات حكوميه مشاركه وفي ايضا جهات اخرى
نتكلم عنها
نتكلم عن مهرجان ويتمر احلى نتكلم عن عرس
ثقافي واجتماعي جميل وهناك الجهات
الحكوميه المشاركه التي هي يعني همم
معناها علاقه في في عمليه تصنيع التمور
والنخيل همم يعني همم الاضافه الى الى
يعني ما هو يقدم خدمات النخيل
والتمور للزوار شكرا جزيلا استاذ خالد
باشا كنت معنا متحدث الرسمي باسم امانه
الاحساء خالد يعني زي ما احنا شايفين
اقبال كبير صراحه وانواع كثيره من التمور
سواء التمور المصنعه المكنوسه المشتقات
التمور الكليجه بالتمر المعمول بالتمر دبس
التمر فمنتجات كثيره صراحه
وايضا من اهل المنطقه الشرقيه
عيونه لك يا خاله تدلل بس ارسل لي على
الواتساب وابشر من عيوني اكيد هالمره ولا
زي كل مره يا عبد الرحمن تعبت ما معك قدام
المشاهدين ما اقدر اهرب خلاص شكرا
سنوات لتحويل سطح منزلي الى مزرعه تنتج
واصنافا متعدده من الفواكه والخضروات
تجربه سهمت في تحقيق العديد من المكاسب
الاقتصاديه تحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي من
انتاج المزرعه المزيد مع مراسلنا على
[موسيقى]
ليس بضروره ان تمتلك ارضا لتنشئه مزرعه
هذا ما فعله هشام الاسعد في مدينه صفوه
شرقي السعوديه والذي استطاع منذ ثلاث
سنوات تحويل السطح منزله الذي تبلغ مساحته
120 متر مربعا الى مزرعه تنتج العديد من
اصناف الفاكهه والخضروات بواسطه المراكز
الزراعيه بدات في الفكره هذه من تقريبا
خلال ثلاث سنوات
الشغله كانت على مراحل الحمد لله الين ما
وصلت الى هذا المستوى الحمدلله ان شاء
الله يكون طيب كانت على مراحل حكم اني
اشتغلت فيها اغلبها انا كنت اتعلم خلال
اليوتيوب او غيره وطبق عندي هنا تضموا
المزرعه ونحو 15 صفر من التين والحمضيات
والتفاح كذلك الموز والمانجو فيما تغطي
الاحتياجات اليوميه من الورقيات وبعض من
الخضروات المزرعه مكونه من 15 سم
بالاضافه الى الحمضيات بانواعها الليمون
البرتقال الافندي
والمانجو والموز الرمان
غير الورقيات والخضروات اللي
تغطي ان شاء الله
احتياج اليوم يقضي هشام جلا وقته داخل
مزرعته للوقوف على مراحل انتاجها والعنايه
فيها والتي تضيفه لمسه جماليه فوق سطح
المنزل ما يجعلها مقصدا لزيارات الاهلي
والاصدقاء اغلب وقت يقضيه في المكان هذا
الكثير من الاقارب والاصدقاء تواصلوا معي
حاولوا يستنسخوا الفكره هذه ويطبقها عندهم
حكم الميزه اللي هي ما تحتاج ارض
جوده الثمار حسب تذوقهم افضل من السوق
كثير الزراعه فوق اسطح المنازل لا يقتصر
اثرها على الفائده الاقتصاديه فحسب بل
تقوم على استغلال المساحات فوق الاسطح
وتحويلها الى مزارعا للحصول على انتاج
يحقق الاكتفاء الذاتي كما انها تساهم في
تقليل استهلاك المياه من مدينه صفوه
المنطقه الشرقيه علي اللقب بالعربيه
تعد العين الحاره الواقعه في قريه تلما
شرقيه محافظه الليث واحده من اهم مواقع
الاستشفاء العلاجيه والسياحيه في مكه
المكرمه الغربيه السعوديه المنطقه
السياحيه التي يقصدها السياح من الداخل
والخارج تضم منتزه العين الحاره الذي احدث
الذي كانت فيه اعماله تطوير قامت بها
الجهات المعانيه شملت اعمال التكسيه حجريه
للمجره
وغيرها من الاعمال
الحديث اكثر ينضم الينا من محافظه الليث
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلميه حياك الله
سلطان ايضا اعطينا فكره عن هذه العين
بكافه المشاهدين قناه العربيه بالفعل
نتواجد في منتزه العين الحاره الواقع في
جنوب منطقه مكه المكرمه وتحديدا في محافظه
الليث هذا المنتجع والمنتزه الذي يعتبر
سياحي وكذلك علاجي يزور الكثير من الاشخاص
بين المواطنين والمؤمنين وحتى السياح من
خارج المملكه للوصول الى هذه لنبي الحاره
التي يصل عددها الى 19 ينبع مياه كبريتيه
تصب في هذه المنطقه
لاستشفى ومعالجه العدد كبير من الامراض
مثل الامراض الحساسيه او حتى
الامراض الجلديه مثل الاكزيما وغير نشاهد
العائلات والاطفال والسياحه وفدوه بشكل
متكر وتحديدا في ايام الاجازات الاسبوعيه
وفتون بشكل مستمر وكبير جدا الى هذه
المنطقه كما تشاهدون اعدادات كبيره من
عائلات ايضا يتواجد اكثر او تتواجد اكثر
من سبعه غرف للساونا مجهزه ومهيئه
الاستفاده منها من قبل المواطنين
والمقيمين والسياح تم تجهيزها من قبل
امانه ال- همم المحافظه للاستفاده منها
كذلك وجود مسبح خاص ايضا للاطفال
والعائلات وكذلك الرجال للاستفاده من هذه
المنطقه
في الامام كم تشاهدون بدء الينابيع في هذه
المنطقه وايضا الملفت الحراره يعني تتدرج
تصل الى 85 درجه مئويه نشاهد زي ما
تشاهدون امامنا العائلات والشباب يستفيدون
من خلال وضع ارجيلهم حتى ايديهم والسباحه
في المسبح من خلال العيون الحاره ايضا
هنالك غرف الساون المخصصه والمجهزه في هذا
المنتجه نظره عليها الان كما تشاهدون
امامكم هذه الغرفه هي مهيئه ومجهزه بشكل
كبير جدا وتصل درجه الحراره فيها الى
درجات عاليه جدا هنالك سبعه غرف تمت
تهيئتها تم ال- الاتهام من مراحل متقدمه
في هذا المشروع المتوقع خلال الفتره
القادمه كذلك الاستفاده بشكل اكبر من
مساحات كبيره جدا عمر هذه المنطقه وهذه
لنبيه يصل الى 300 عام ايضا نتحدث على تم
تايه الموقع بجلسات عائليه والعاب اطفال
وكذلك همم مسطحات خضراء وايضا غرف الساونه
وغيرها من مرات المشاهده تحدث انه كما
ذكرنا عدد العيون يصل الى 19 عين نتحدث
ارتفاع هذه المنطقه عن سطح البحر يصل الى
165 مساحه الاجماليه لهذه المنطقه تصل الى
تسعه واربعين همم متر ايضا تحدث انه كثير
من الاهالي والاخواني يحرصون على زياره
هذه المنطقه بشكل متكرر للسياحه
الاستشفائيه والاستمتاع بالمناظر الطبيعيه
الاساسيه ما بعد الاجواء الربيعيه التي
تشهدها محافظه الليث ايضا هنالك اهتمام
كبير من قبل الجهات المعنيه ليكون هذا
المنطقه يعني موردا اقتصاديا مهما من خلال
زياره السياح وكل الراغبين السياحه
الاستشفائيه في هذه المنطقه طبعا هنالك تم
تصميم هذه البحيره وهذا المنتجه لتكون
درجات الحراره تبدا من 85 ومن ثم تنزل
تدريجيا وصول الى المسبح حتى يتم
الاستفاده من كافه هذه المياه الكبريتيه
التي تعمل على معالجه الالتهابات والمفاصل
وامراض الامراض الجلديه وغيرها من المناطق
الامراض المهمه والحساسه التي كثير من هذه
الحصول على زيارتها بشكل مستمر يعني هذه
المياه حاره ان اتكلم تحديد لا استطيع
بشكل كبير ووضع يدي فيها في هذه المنطقه
التي تبدا التي هي مصدر الانابيع لكن في
المناطق الاخرى يستطيع الشباب والعائله
السباحه والاستمتاع بهذه المياه الكبريتيه
الحاره نعم شكرا لك ايضا همم لكل الزملاء
المحافظه
في مستجدات جائعات كورونا اكدت السلطات
الصينيه ان ذروه موجه فيروس كورونا في
البلاد انتهت وسطه مخاوف السابقه من تفشي
العدوى حيث عدم مئات الملايين الى مسقط
راسهم لقضاء عطله السنه القمريه الجديده
التي كانت توصف قبل الجائحه بانها اكبر
حركه تنقلات سنويه في العالم كانت الصين
قد تخلت بشكل المفاجئ الشهر الماضي
شمل عمليات اغلاق جماعي اذكى احتجاجات غير
مسبوقه في انحاء البلاد في اواخر نوفمبر
واعادت فتحه حدودها اخي
قبل ذلك كشفت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
ارتفاع الاعداد الوفيات الناجمه عن فيروس
كورونا بنسبه 20% في الفتره ما بين ال 19
من ديسمبر والخامس عشر من يناير وذلك
بالمقارنه بالايام 28 السابقه وفيما وصلت
خالته الوفيات الى 53,000 حاله
اضافت المنظمه انه تم الابلاغ عن نحو 13
مليون حاله اصابه انخفاض قدره 7% خلال
الفتره ذاتها
ومن جهته اعلن رئيس الوزراء الياباني
فوميو كوشه ان بلاده خفض التصنيف مرض كبد
19 الى فئه الم انفلونزا بدايه من الربيع
القادم
لقد اكدتم حكومته على تعزيز المناقشات بين
الخبراء حول خطوات اعاده تصنيف فايروس
كروم الجديد وخفضي فئه المرض اذا الفئه
خمسه في هذا الربيع
سنراجع ايضا ارتداء اقنعه الوجه وغيرها من
الاجراءات المعديه ضد انتشار الفايروس
اعلن الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه الفا بيت
الملكه لجوجل ساندر باتشان في مذكره
داخليه الشركات ستخفض عدد موظفيها ب 12000
وظيفه قلبك
الذي جاء بعد مراجعه شامله لاقسامه
ونشاطات الشركه التي توضع 190 الف
واضافت شركه جوجل بان عمليات التسريح
عالميه وهي تؤثر على الموظفين الامريكيين
باثر فوري شركه مايكروسوفت المنافس سبق ان
قامت بالخطوه ذاتها قبل فتره وسراحت عشره
الاف
انتهت بطوله كاس الخليج العربيه
بفوز البلد المضيف بالكاس العراقي نجح
ايضا في تامين البطوله حيث اظهر العراقيون
الخراطهم مع اشقائهم العرب منذ اول يوم من
انطلاق البطوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد وجه رئيس الحكومه العراقيه محمد
شاهين السوداني باتقاد التدابير الامنيه
لاستقبال المنتخب العراقي في العاصمه
بغداد بعد فوزه بطوله كاس الخليج العربي
التي اقيمت في محافظه البصره وطلع سوداني
على الوضع الامني والميداني الخاص بتامين
احتفالات العراقين اليوم الجمعه في بغداد
عبر رشاشات المراقبه في مقر قياده
العمليات المشتركه
احتجزت الشرطه الاسبانيه لعب فريق برشلونه
السابق البرازيلي الداني الفيش وذكر موقعه
لافان غوارديا الاخباريه الاسبانيه بانه
تم استدعائه اللاعب من قبل الشرطه في اطار
تحقيق حول مزاعم ارتكابه الاعتداء الجنسي
في ملهم ليلي في الثلاثين من ديسمبر 2022
افاد الموقع بان اللاعب نفرتيكا به اي
اعتداء قد تم نقله الى المحكمه ليقرر
القضاء الاجراءات التي قد تتخذوا بحقه
خلالها فتره التحقيق
العناوي
وكيف تعلن حاله التاهب الجوي
الدعم مقابله لاصلاح السعوديه تدعوا الدول
الى تحمل مسؤوليتها تجاه المناحي
للتصدي للعواصف الترابيه اكثر من نصف
مليار دولار حجم الخسائر
رابعه تجول في عيون محافظه الليث التربيه
السعوديه وجهه علاجيه وسياحيه للمئات
والاحساء تحتضن النسخه الثامنه من مهرجان
وي التمر احلام اليدويه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]